Being at Columbia really shaped the
trajectory of my own scholarship. I began
to produce works that were I would say
much more historical but kind of turned
my eye toward New York and toward Harlem
in my scholarship and I'm not sure that
that would have ever happened had I not
come here and had I not been working
with scholars who were also doing
innovative exciting things-- actually I
feel like they were producing fields, and
not just producing fields in producing
books, but finding young scholars like I
was at the time and encouraging us and
nurturing us and providing a place where
we could do the work and that's what I'd
like to see this department continue to
do, I'd like for it to be a kind of
laboratory for young scholars who like I
had been to really do their best work
and perhaps find some strengths they
didn't even know they had